anyway uh zielinski also became Time
magazine's person of the year look at
him like a Star Wars character
everything is this is what they do with
everything now right it's one big face
and then Small Faces around it just like
he is from Revenge of the Sith oh lordy
lordy okay so why am I telling you all
of this because I want to show you first
the show portion of all of this this man
is under no threat he is obviously not
worried he is not starving he is meeting
celebrities he's talking to the Grammys
he's in it with Hollywood he's getting a
[ __ ] ton right that's a technical term
of cash his wife can you confirm the
number on this for me I'm fairly certain
went to Paris last week and spent forty
thousand dollars on jewelry and bags we
just will get the confirmation on that
thing uh but yes uh zielinski is uh is
meeting with everybody you may remember
this uh remember we're in the middle of
a war in Ukraine for some reason all of
our politicians can just show up there
nobody's wearing helmets nobody's
worried they're going to get bombed
here's Mitch McConnell in his tan pants
just showing up and saying hi to
zielinski
hello
nice to meet you
thank you thank you so much
thank you
we know each other a little bit yeah
I'm gonna just see you again
yeah yeah
how do we invite our delegation also to
join
as you can see guys the threat of War
because you know Mitch McConnell if
there was a war and people you know he
sends a lot of people to war and he
likes putting a lot of money into war
but he often doesn't go to the war zones
right so you could see he was really
freaked out you know with the slacks and
the pictures and the whole thing uh yeah
okay Zippity Dippity